your stories if you when you and i sat
and i said i said johnny if if 10 of the
stories you're telling me is true you'll
live the ridiculous life let me kind of
remind the audience who's maybe hasn't
seen or heard all the stories they're
here for the first time let me kind of
uh share some of the stories here with
them so so here's what we got you one of
them you
you
claim you lost your virginity to marilyn
monroe at 15. 15 and a half yeah 15 and
a half and you spent three days with her
well i went to look after her i want to
set the stage straight
she was staying at the at the um
walled up astoria as a guest of mr
costello who basically took me under his
wing at 12 years old so i was already
working for him for three and a half
years he was going deep-sea fishing
people don't realize he loved to fish
with tony acado the boss of the alpha to
chicago
so he said we have a guest at the hotel
this weekend go i knew the suites they
kept
and
i went up there
but what he didn't realize
because when i got caught on the streets
at fort at 15
a tune officer saw me in front of
lindy's and he said what are you doing
on the street that's what you're talking
about because he had a brown uniform i
said who knows this guy i knew he was in
a cop he's on my tune officer i said
what do you do
he said i'm catching kids like you why
aren't you in school i said what are you
talking about i don't go to school i
have like 5 000 in my pocket already
because i'm running stuff for him
she's got to go to school so he gives me
a ticket and i was on the way
to to to chores it was one of my stops
everybody was every day late afternoon
joe dimaggio jackie gleason because he
was doing the show from the cbs right
there
and i walk in with the ticket
and costello says to me how did you get
a ticket walking too fast what's this
and he looked at it and he said she's a
true officer
he's how old are you i said 15.
he said well you got to go to school in
new york state until you're 16. i said i
don't want to go to school so he put me
in wilford academy hairdressing school
which was on my route
so he's just stopped by sign in until
six months in december you'll be sixteen
and forget about it
so i go in there
it's nine o'clock in the morning
twenty thirty gorgeous little girls
so i was on the way to meet him and 11
o'clock was already dressed so i used to
go there a day or two i mean an hour or
two every day
and mark sinclair and kenneth
came in biggest hairdressers in new york
looking for shampoo boys
and i was a good-looking guy when i was
dressed
not like these other kids because i was
going to meet him
and they picked me
the fourth had a hair at lily dashes on
56th and park was milo monroe's
they and it was not like we go to a
salon here and as well lined up sinks
private rooms
literally that [ __ ] was a haberdasher
two-story building kenneth was the
featured dr uh hairdresser and mark
sinclair was a colorist
and i didn't i thought when they said
they were partners they owned the
business they were partners and like we
know them today partners are very open
so long story short the fourth head of
hair i go in
and it's melon monroe
and she's already in the you know
shampoo base look at this and i don't
even know how long i was looking at her
and she's is someone here i said excuse
me
yes i'm sorry and they give you a card
nobody's name's on it
you know what the shampoo the rinse that
you gotta they teach you to test the
water and put it on the inside of her
wrist she has to okay the water
now nobody knows
a lot of times in the winter especially
i used to go to
new york paramount obviously in
paramount still in my world for now the
last 50 years
they used to be open 24 hours a day
i saw some like it hot
maybe 50 times and i was masturbating up
in in the balcony at 15.
she's singing i want to make love to you
in this sheer dress in the film
now i'm starting to massage as you want
the strong massage yeah there's issues
they have great pictures
but anyway i'm massaging and she starts
moaning
like you know
now we know the configuration of a
shampoo basin so my three-piece set's on
her shoulders
and as i'm massaging her
i get an erection
now i don't know why and you're 15 at
the time
who wouldn't 15. looking at this in a
row but i'm trying to look into it it's
freaking marilyn monroe that's what i'm
talking about she's moaning no
i'm visualizing all kinds of things but
now
what no i had a towel dry a hand i'm
drying it yeah like i was gonna wear
because i'm thinking how am i gonna walk
from here to the station i got this
teepee in my face
how am i going to walk out there
everybody we look at them especially
these you know these guys that
had their vision on me anyway classic
and then she started requesting me
always a big tipper too i kept
and i not that i needed mike because i
was making good money with costello but
i kept one check she gave me for fifty
dollars i can't even tell you what it's
worth today you have it till today hello
you still have a check signed by marilyn
monroe i hear pillowcase that she kissed
signed by monroe
and
i'm writing my second book which will be
out there this christmas which is ironic
that you said come on
because the last time my book came out
three years ago he's still a bestseller
hollywood godfather my life in the movie
and the mom
and
now
what nobody realized when the last
weekend i spent with a cal neva
when she went crazy on bobby kennedy and
we found out all kinds of news we didn't
want to know we knew they were going to
kill her and she was dead five days
later
i called from cal never because her and
i had a cat together
merlin monroe you know in her apartment
but i knew marilyn you know she
some she disappeared for a week you
don't know where she went so i had this
lady taking care of the cat
so i called her i said do me a favor
marilyn's coming home because joe
dimaggio he called cal never
and he asked sinatra it's what's going
on she wants me to come and get his mind
your own business don't come here and he
was in san francisco
and he didn't come if he came she'd
probably still be alive well she'd be
100 today but but he could have saved
the life he did she'd be 100 today
101 yeah 101 but johnny follow-up
question i mean we're talking about
marilyn monroe here so you're the
shampoo boy good looking guy suited up
you got a tp in your pants you're
hanging out how does it transition to
your 15 and a half almost 16 to actually
having sex losing your virginity to my
life no i never talk this
two or three women i never had sex with
i made love to
one of them grace kelly her there's
certain people you hold the royal grace
kelly by the way i don't know if you
caught that it was right in there yeah
pull up a picture of grace kelly if you
don't mind
if you don't mind walk us through the
white house
costello
a guest in the hotel i don't know who's
up there
so he's don't go up before noon so i go
knock on the door
that's an amazing woman yeah
she used to stay at the barbers on on
well you know where i live she lived on
63rd
and lexington the barber's arm was a
hotel just for women her family were in
mason business in philadelphia they sent
her the ad for finishing school you're
talking about grace kelly yeah okay
audrey hepburn all of that
costello used to say go get flowers for
the table i knew where i had to go he
gave me money i go upstairs get the
money take a cab i never took the cab i
walked i kept the money i took the care
back but i picked these girls up so i
got to know them for two or three years
while they were finishing school before
she became a princess that's how crazy
this is but how big was maryland but at
the at this time huge so you go up to
something like it hot the biggest movie
in the world
they send you up to her hotel room
i knock on the door she opens it at
terry cloth road he says johnny what are
you doing here i said well mr c told me
to look in on you so she knew you by now
for sure well i was a shampoo boy hello
so i was already shampoo and hair for
three four months
so i come in she's i just ordered
breakfast come in i had room service i
didn't even know what room service was
you know i was i never was in the rooms
i was outside them she had all these
carts i said i already had breakfast
i said i'm just supposed to check on you
sit down i said mr seal get mad do you
need any johnny sit down so i sat down
she had the calista champagne i started
laughing i said i'm 15. she knew how old
you were i was like yeah well you could
tell
i told i was 15.
i can't drink i don't have to be 18 a
drink in new york
she gives me a glass of champagne so i'm
getting a buzz
so i'm going to take a bath i swear
listen i'll be downstairs just call
downstairs they all know the kid because
that was my name in the hotel
just tell them whatever you want no no
come with me she takes me by the hand in
the bathroom she turns the water on
and she sits down she's brush out my
hair you always you know from the salon
i did it anyway
so she lowers the robe and i'm saying
that i'm not going to get in trouble yet
today forget about it i'm brushing out
here
she's i mean
today she's exotic woman
not thin velvet shoes
especially up
so now i'm brushing out here
she walks over to the tub shops off the
water and she drops her rope she got
nothing
she's getting the tub with me i said
you're gonna get me killed so who's
gonna know
so now i couldn't get my clothes off
fast enough
and i get in the other side the bottom
of the back of the tub
adam you need a break or are you good
yeah guys i'm going to take a check in
here okay adam looks like he's what's he
doing we're talking about marilyn monroe
here what are we talking about no but so
now what happens is
that was a saturday afternoon
out of respect that was a saturday
afternoon i left monday morning
so that whole weekend you're just
staying there it's late they're with us
and you're saying you made love not sex
that's right who was the third person he
said grace kelly marilyn monroe number
three was i can't imagine the other one
oh really royalty really the third one
you can't mention
so royalty above grace kelly yeah
believe it i heard you i had a
conversation with brando
and he says i don't believe you straight
up he called you out he goes i don't
believe that you had sex monroe
he says tell me something that nobody
would know
tony curtis yeah all of us
sinatra
she
that's that's what's
she's so naive
that's all she thought she can give you
is her body can i make you happy
she didn't even think of it that way
and if you were with her there's she has
a scar
just where her leg joins her cleavage
unless you whether you never see that so
that's the if you're really with marilyn
yeah where's the scar it's down here
okay the crease gotcha
how big is this car
not that not that big but but it's
wonderful oh no so if you've been with
maryland you made love with maryland
you're going to notice this guy
yeah so if you enjoyed this little
segment from the podcast click over here
to watch the entire podcast and if
you've not subscribed to the channel
please do so take care everybody
[Music]